the drop-off point at liverpool women's
hospital in northwest england it's just
before 11am there's an explosion then
the driver can be seen getting out and
several people rushed to help him
he was injured but has now been released
from hospital
by the time fire crews arrived the taxi
was in flames and the passenger was dead
inside the vehicle
liverpool's mayor has called the
driver's actions heroic saying they
avoided in her words an absolutely awful
disaster i can't comment on the on the
details or or exactly what type of uh
incident it was what type of crime it
may have been
but it does look as though the taxi
driver in question did behave uh with
incredible presence of mind and bravery
this has now been declared a terrorist
incident
counter-terrorism police have been
involved in the investigation since
sunday hours after the incident police
arrested three men all in their twenties
at the same property in liverpool a
fourth person's now been detained police
say they found significant items at one
address
it is not clear what the motivation for
this incident is
our inquiries indicate that an
improvised explosive device has been
manufactured and our assumption so far
is that it was built by the passenger in
the taxi
the reason why he then took it to the
women's hospital is unknown
as is the reason for its sudden
explosion
police say the passenger had asked to go
to the hospital but they're checking
whether there's any link with
remembrance day events nearby
nadim baba al-jazeera